big day tomorrow Autumn statement what
are you going to be looking out for
the key for us is to look at whether the
government are making Fair choices where
it comes to taxation in particular so
we'll be doing things differently
whether it's ending that non-dom tax
status charging v80 on private schools
putting that money into State education
there's a lot of areas really that the
government have got some straightforward
choices I think around fairness but also
on growth you know we've had terrible
growth these last 12 years as a country
obviously we're facing particularly
acute pressures at the moment on the
cost of living because the conservatives
crashed the economy and the fact we're
having tomorrow is as a result of that
failure but this isn't just a more
recent problem we've had a terrible
record as a country on growth and
Labor's green Prosperity plan is about
delivering that growth with high paid
you know what good jobs secure jobs in
every corner of our country you say that
it's because the conservatives crash the
economy it's a bit more complicated than
that though isn't it obviously not you
know completely negating the impact of
the mini budget but we are housing a
global inflation crisis we're seeing a
war in Ukraine we're seeing what
happened with Putin as well they crash
the economy and they've mismanaged it
for 12 years so if you've been in charge
of 12 years you've had a long time to
make choices about the direction of our
country I mean undeniably there are
Global factors of course every country
is confronted with some of this but
doesn't explain why we're bottom of the
pile where it comes to growth we are
we're uniquely exposed as a country
going into this crisis the fact that we
are so dependent our energy security you
know we don't have that independence of
supply and part of Labor's plan is about
making sure that in future we're not so
exposed to those kinds of global
fluctuations but this is squarely on
them the fact that people are going to
be paying more on their mortgages every
month is because of the decisions of the
conservative party
um Jeremy Hunt's been pretty upfront
that there is going to be a public
spending squeeze as well there's been
strong hints that the NHS is going to be
protected that the pensions triple lock
is going to be protected that benefits
will be rising in line with inflation
are you a bit worried about what that
means for education in your department
I'm incredibly worried about the
pressure that our schools are under at
the moment and when I speak to heads
when I speak to teachers and support
staff they are doing amazing work
working so hard but the challenges and
the pressure you know they see it every
day with children arriving at school who
haven't had that good start that they
need where their families are struggling
to give them the best that's why labor
would deliver breakfast clubs for every
Primary School child so they get a good
start to the day but the pressures that
schools are under having to make
decisions about whether they're going to
have to lose staff or whether they can
afford to give children the basics I
think one really straightforward way
that the government could fill some of
that would be to end the tax benefits
that private schools enjoy and how much
more into that race though that race is
1.7 billion pounds not going to really
touch the scientists that I think it
would make a big difference you look at
the number of teachers that you could
recruit six and a half thousand new
teachers better mental health support in
our schools careers guidance for all of
our children it gets you a lot and I
don't think you can go around seeing
that you've got choices to make and not
consider the really straightforward easy
choices there is no justification for
that kind of taxpayer subsidy of private
schools and it's the opportunity for the
chancellor on Thursday to end that and
to put that money into the schools that
support the vast majority of our
children you've talked about the
pressures that we're under whether it's
inflation but also of course a borrowing
and borrowing costs
um are there any areas of public
spending where you think actually yes
this is where we could look at finding
spend savings
I think it's quite tough I mean there
has been a big squeeze over the last 12
years I mean we do believe that you need
to make sure you're getting value for
money that's why we've said that labor
would set up the office of value for
money to make sure that we're getting
real value from everything any areas
where you think that look maybe this if
we have to make difficult choices this
is the department where maybe they could
fall
um there will you know no government is
perfect in how it spends its money and
of course you should be looking at
getting the best out of the money that
you're spending but I don't think if I
look for example across education it's
not that they are Awash with money and
have got more money than they know what
to do with I mean unlike the oil and gas
companies who haven't actually been
taxed for what they have been enjoying
at the moment so I think all of this
comes down to choices for government
both in terms of priorities but also tax
fairness that is the key though isn't
the choice as the government which I
guess is why I'm asking you know if
there is any areas where you think
savings could be found well I'd always
be up to looking for it but
I think given the pressures that our
public sector has been under these last
12 years whether it's our schools or
hospitals an awful lot has been cut back
and cut back to such a point that for
example with Schools they're the last
line of defense really for so many of
our communities that wider
infrastructure that wider support that
families need that's gone and so much of
it falls to school so actually if you
had to free up if you get high standards
and excellence in all of our schools you
could deliver that far more effectively
if you had that wider support available
to All Families so that doesn't always
just brought to our teachers and school
leaders and I want to ask you about
dominant Robb who obviously is facing
allegations of bullying and there's
going to be in independent investigation
into his conduct he says he welcomes it
he'll comply are you satisfied with that
well we don't know who as yet is to lead
this independent inquiry of course the
Prime Minister hasn't appointed his
independent ethics advisor he promised
us a government that would be rooted in
Integrity professionalism and
accountability this Falls a long way
short but it's not just about about
Dominic Robb you look at sowella
bravaman back in the cabinet having
breached the ministerial court on an
issue of National Security Gavin
Williamson put back into government I
think this speaks to a deeper question
as to Rishi seen next character and also
his weakness that he feels so weak
within his own party that he is doing
what he feels is right by his party it
should be about what's right for the
country that isn't what's happening
right now I just wonder if you think it
also speaks to a deeper problem in
Westminster and like trying to sort of
take the kind of Party politics out of
this um you know Sky News has a podcast
where two of our reporters have been
looking into allegations of bullying the
Open Secret podcast and they found
examples across all parties one as staff
are telling them I'm sure every staffer
in Parliament has got some a story even
if they weren't bullied they know
someone who was I mean is there a
problem with bullying and the treatment
of Staff in Westminster I think you get
uh you know real problems where you have
an imbalance of power and where people
don't feel able to make complaints a map
for too long has been the case in
Westminster and you know we do have a
process now and I hope that people will
come forward where they have been on the
end of poor treatment in the workplace
because no matter where you work you
should be treated with respect and you
shouldn't be subjected to bullying and
the same is true of course right across
government as well and sometimes people
don't feel comfortable coming forward
they want to try and just plow on and do
their best but no one should feel under
that kind of pressure and I think you do
see what happens when you have a more
open culture where people do feel that
they can come forward and you know we've
got more work to do in Westminster
absolutely but I think it does come down
to that that Dynamic around the
imbalance of power and you know we all
of us as politicians have a
responsibility to make sure that you
know we are respectful of others you
know politics can involve you know
robust exchange that's as it should be
but you don't cross that line thank you
very much for being on the program thank
you